we all have our favorite characters in
Game of Thrones but let's face it they
aren't always known for making the best
decisions whether it's screwing over a
key ally screwing up a delicate
political situation or screwing someone
they shouldn't some of those groups have
pretty far-reaching and most of the time
and deadly repercussions here's seven of
the biggest mistakes Game of Thrones
characters have made you think in a
battle of life and death that a you
wouldn't have a cheeky pint before you
fought a man three times your size and B
you'd make sure that the half giant is
completely dead before starting your
victory dance Oberyn Martell
underestimated the mountains grapping
range and started his one-man Mexican
wave just a tad too soon oh you're dead
it was all left his head looking like
someone threw up a red velvet cake
if you have an alliance that hinges on
you marrying someone's daughter deciding
to marry someone else then going to a
wedding in the house of the family you
slighted with your new hot and very
pregnant wife is a recipe not only for
an episode of Jerry Springer but for a
complete disaster so sorry Robb Stark
you basically shot yourself in the foot
head and body multiple times with this
one agreeing to become the hand of the
King wasn't Ned's biggest mistake it was
actually when he told Cersei Lannister
that he knew that the father of her
three children was actually her twin
brother Jaime when you play the game of
Thrones you win you die
there is no middle ground admittedly he
was doing this out of duty to try and
protect her and her illegitimate
children as well as making sure that the
rightful heir ends up on the Iron Throne
unfortunately for Ned they sparked a
chain of events that led to Cersei
thinks she's much cleverer than she
actually is and rarely did any of her
Harebrained Schemes ever really pan out
like restoring a religious military
order that she ultimately had no control
over who inevitably turned on her and
punished her for all those crimes that
she's committed like regicide treason
and incest and what better way to let
the punishment fit the crime and to
strip her Schaefer and marcher through
the streets shame shame shame where do
you even start with the mistakes that
Stannis is made let's see he fails to
ally with Renly or Robb Stark to take on
the land stirs he sails his superior
force into an enclosed Harbor or he's
for them to get trapped by a giant chain
and then destroyed by wildfire he puts
all his face into a red greased s it
gets caught up in the northern snow with
no food or supply lines and then then
decides to sacrifice his own daughter to
try and curry some favor with the Lord
of Light only to have his wife hang
herself army dessert and then get
sentenced to death by Brienne of Tarth
house danny's while Jon certainly has
his allies in the Nights Watch certainly
enough to get him voted into the top
position as well commander he has his
fair share of enemies - enemies that he
manages to boylee piss off he had the
option to send head troublemaker
Alice a thorn to the far-flung reaches
of the wall hell even Stannis suggested
that he sends her Alliser away being
perhaps the only good idea that Stannis
has ever had but instead Jon lets him
Swan about Castle black
Wester alice' forms a mutinous band of
brothers who then stabbed Jon over and
over and over again lesson learned but
the biggest mistake made by the vast
majority of characters in Game of
Thrones is placing even an ounce of
trust in Petyr Littlefinger Baelish the
bizarrely accented master of coin is
pretty much solely responsible for the
downfall of the stark family as well as
numerous others he organized the murder
of Jon Arryn by manipulating Lysa
he told Catelyn that the weapon used in
brans murder attempt belong to Tyrion to
make the Starks go after the Lannisters
he marries Lysa to get a title and some
land before pushing her at the moon door
he made best friends with the Lannisters
only to conspire to kill Joffrey with
eleven Tyrell and he orchestrates the
marriage between Sansa and Ramsay the
list goes on and on
I mean Littlefinger says it the best
himself I did warn you not to trust me
so there we are the biggest mistakes
made by our favorites in Westeros did I
miss any chuck them in the comments
below for more GameSpot of Thrones head
to youtube.com / GameSpot or of course
find us on games.com all men must
subscribe